any issues with the
doubts feel free to ask oh yeah sure
so this is the this is a link this is
the link for the photographer and this
is a total tutorial so feel free to ask
questions or comments in the middle of
the tutorial so we're not going to have
a Q&A at the end of it it's you can ask
questions in the middle any issues with
the setup cool so raise off by raise of
hands how many of you are pretty
comfortable with Python kukuku
how many of you are comfortable with
pandas like a group by something that
you have done before
that's nice so let's start before we
start what do you think what kind of
networks are we going to talk about
today any ideas any cases came up so ah
yeah but yes
Game of Thrones so the networks we're
going to talk about today's are not like
computer networks not like not exactly
computer networks that you study in your
CS curriculum it's more the mathematical
networks which comes from graph theory
so let's start so like this this is a
mathematical definition of a network of
a network or graph that you have objects
and you have relationships between those
objects and those are called edges and
this is how you define a network like
this is a network like you have nodes
and you have edges between them and now
these objects can be anything
these can be game strong characters thin
these can be US airports these can be
proteins and how different proteins
interact so you can model pretty much
anything as a network you can model
these network you can model these nodes
as politicians and you know how they
interact with other politicians so it's
a cool area to work in
so any example of networks and real
world networks that we can see at all
anyone Facebook Twitter for examples
road networks Google Maps these are all
examples so DNS did like how like how
are you how you resolve these requests
these are all networks so to to have fun
with these networks first we need to
learn a bit about network X which is a
library in Python which is used to like
in a model graphs and networks and
analyze them and play around with so and
the good thing about networking says
it's it has a very intuitive API so like
if you want to create a new network or a
graph you just plug in T and X graph and
voila and if you want to access nodes G
nodes and similarly for edges G edges
and so ok so let's create a recipe
Network has anyone heard of recipe
Network before I hope no one because I'm
proud of this thing that I like I think
that I came up with this but I'm not
sure so I I have this idea of crawling
all the recipe websites and like you
know trying to figure out like trying to
get all ingredients and if if two
ingredients are in a similar in the same
recipe there is an edge between them and
that's how you populate the network
so I created a bit let's create a very
small network out of this like so you
have tomato Tomatoes eggs lamb and
chicken so you end up with something
like this like this is a very small
recipe Network so what can be analyzed
the can we figure out something from
this network anyone what what can we say
again can you say anything about this
network about the ingredients yeah
tomato Tomatoes are really useful this
is you know something we can infer from
that from this network and if we have
the bigger Network which is crawled
using all the websites maybe if we can
find like you can maybe we can find the
the magic ingredient for maybe Indian
food or like it opium food or you know
different food different food networks
maybe I haven't done that so I'm not
going to claim anything so let's escape
this so one more important thing how
Network X deals with graph data
structures so G is our network object
it's represented as a graph object and
underneath it's just a dictionary of a
dictionary of a dictionary and what do I
mean by that so suppose I do this T of
tomato it will give me a view of all the
adjacent edges like all the edges in
notes which is which it is connected to
in our case it's tomato is connected to
X lamb and chicken so we'll get all of
them and if we go one step further and
if we do X it will give us a empty
dictionary but we can have attributes on
the edges too like we can give more
property more properties to this edge in
this case and suppose if we are calling
the whole recipe Network maybe we can
have the number of mentions as a weight
on the edge that tomatoes and eggs are
used hundred are used in hundred
different recipes together so that can
give us more information about this
network so a quick introduction that was
a good intro to Network X
and now we have only 90 minutes so let's
just jump in into a real world Network
so how many of you know about archive
the archive just think so so it's a so
it's a repository for research papers so
this is an extract out of that for
general general relativity and so if two
people have authored a paper together
they average between them and this
network the node our researchers and
edges are if they have authored a paper
together and suppose if six people have
authored a paper together you'll have a
network like this a complete sixth
network in which every author is
connected to every other author in the
network no not in the network in the in
the paper so let's read the graph and we
see we see that there are around five
thousand researchers and fourteen
thousand nodes and you know this is an
example of so this is a non mais data so
we don't you know the names it's like
author number three four six six this
has worked with these people so now an
interesting thing that you know you can
try to find out out of this is can we
find influential researchers like who is
the most important research earn enough
in this field there are standard
academic measures like no citations at
index eight and index people in academia
would know what I'm talking about
academia is weird we get that so can we
find an influential researcher and I can
think that depends how you define
influence but like we have created a
network out of it like you know we know
how people collaborate and collaboration
is an important part of doing research
at least in the current in this current
era so can we use network science to
find important people in this network so
it's an exercise for for everyone you
have to create a list of two tuples and
find the node find the researcher with
maximum degree which is the maximum
number of neighbors so you we have like
three minutes for this so go ahead
how many of you are doing the exercises
so that's good
when questions comments feel free to
pass that
did anyone end up with this 81 you don't
win a prize so sorry so so apparently
the author not apparently we know that
author 2 1 0 1 2 has 81 different
connections which means this person has
collaborated with 81 different
researchers does that mean anything does
that mean this person is important
somehow we don't know let's try to
figure it out so how do you measure
important this is a million-dollar
question in network science not a
million billion another question so
suppose I give you a Twitter network of
like you know who follows WHO and you
know all the details about that how do
you what's the first thing that comes to
your mind when when I say an influential
Twitter personality is there any
objective metric that you can come up
with for finding the most influential
Twitter person yes that like some of our
like the number of followers and that's
a pretty straightforward and like no it
makes sense right in the number of
followers should be an important metric
in Twitter and that's what degree is but
because Twitter is a directed Network
it's kind of different so we talked
about that later
so when this exercise we found out that
2 2 1 0 1 2 is the most like me
be friendly researcher because a lot of
people collaborate with this person so a
fancy way of saying like know what we
did just now is called degree centrality
it's a centrality centrality measures
are basically told you know find the
influential notes and so degree
centrality is a fancy way of saying the
counting number of neighbors and
normalizing it by n minus 1 where n is
the total number of nodes in the network
which is basically n minus 1 is the is
the maximum number of connect
connections our node can have the
network in a normal network so we find
degree centrality and we get this so
exercise 2 let's plot a histogram of
degree centrality of authors graph of a
of this network
and people who are
from living like matplotlib like this is
how you plot a histogram
PLT dot hist a list of values were list
is a list of values a list of values
did anyone end up with this looking
graph or a histogram so can we infer
anything from this graph anyone this is
the plot of the number of neighbors that
each node has yes so like you can see
that no majority of researchers don't
like you know work with a lot of
different people but there are few
people at the end of the tail who work
with a lot of different people and this
is something that will seem Twitter -
right
not everyone has millions of followers
there will be few people towards the end
of the towards the end of the tail hula
who laughs like millions of followers
but majority of us I hope in this room
have like you know maybe under 200
followers and that that's what make up
the the bigger part of this graph so
we're going to take a detour and talk
about something which I find very
interesting I'm sorry were for that so
in 1960s like of graph theory was really
picking up steam and like a know in
academic mathematical research and so
they they came up with a random graph
model like everyone was looking for one
random graph model I want to make a
random graph I don't have access to date
like real world data I want to make a
random graph so these two people Paul
Erdos and Renny came up with a model for
a graph that was a very straight forward
model that there's a I'll just attach a
probability of having edge between any
two nodes as X
and that's my random graph model and
they did that and when you create a
graph model like that you'll end up with
something like this for their degree
distribution like in this case I
provided a probability of 0.3 and you
see that it's a Bernoulli distributed
graph at which speaks at 0.3 it's fine
it makes sense but what we saw just
right now was something which was very
different these are very different
graphs right and the first one is
supposed supposedly a real-world Network
and this is a random network so this was
so like no more research happened you
know can we try to create a random model
that somehow depicts real-world so in
late 90s they came up with this like two
people Barabbas II and Elbert came up
with this model called the barabási
Elbert graph and when you plot that out
you'll find this these two are kind of
similar the
they're not exactly similar but they
follow the same trend the trend of
exponential DK which is known as power
law and you know in network science that
so their hypothesis was that every
real-world Network follows a power law
like this you cannot have randomly
distributed edges because this is how a
real world networks work we are not
going to go into the maths of behind
that but this was their basic intuition
and there is a lot of debate right now
look if it's statistically right or
wrong but that's a different story so
what this is the takeaway that real
world networks kind of follow power law
if not exactly a power law but they have
a exponential decay trained for their
degree distribution which is the number
of nodes every node has in the graph
then now let's come back so
another important thing that we should
know about networks is sometimes having
a network like this is very bad
suppose this is a road network we
suppose you are mayor of your mayor like
you're president of your country and you
have cities and you are planning new
roads and this is the current state of
your road networks and there is nothing
stopping to have a road between 7:00 and
9:00 it's not it's not it's not like
there on some islands if you have a
network like this it's a very bad road
network you don't want people stuck in
city seven and eight to not have access
to real not real world but the other
part of the country so you should
sometimes you shouldn't have this in
your network and sometimes sometimes
it's good to compact compartmentalize so
you should know about this so let's use
this idea in our authors graph can we
find people so our motive here is to
find out do people do research
independently do they have their own
cliques of doing research or like know
everyone collaborates and you can
somehow go from one person to another
person in this network by know by
jumping between mutual collaborators so
when you try to do that we find that
like out of 5,000 4,000 of them to
collaborate they are in the same big
component and but you are still people
you know who don't really collaborate
with other people who testament to their
own work and then we have this one
lonely person one lone wolf who doesn't
like to like you know work with anyone
else and they publish their papers alone
fine maybe they had that spot so so
let's now this create some sub graphs
out of it by subgraphs I mean like you
know every component itself is a graph
and if we try to let know draw some
random graph not random graph from this
sample
so we see that the we have like we have
like six people in this part and three
people in this part so maybe it's like
no this person is a Reese like this
person those two like you know these
collaborators and these kilometers so
this person is a blue between these two
research groups something that that
another very important application
shortest path in a network if you there
are well-known algorithms for this like
you know the basic one is to do just do
DFS of BFS you'll find the shortest path
if you have weights you do Dijkstra like
this is like you know this is what we
learn in DSA and when we don't know
graphs and like this has very like
nobody who if you are working for Google
Maps this is something that you would be
interested in like when while you are
creating routing algorithms this is
important thing to know about so we
should know about this so suppose if I
could so suppose if I try to find a
network X has these algorithms
implemented already so you don't have to
write your own DFS every time that you
need to do this so suppose if you want
to if I want to find shortest path
between 8 and 3 you will see that it's
not possible so networks will give you
an error so it will help you with that
and so let's you know this is like
trying to find the distance between two
different authors you'll see that it's
difference of 6 if you want to jump from
two to five zero four two two three nine
nine one author so it's time for an
exercise again people who have heard
about six degrees of freedom
and someone tell me that
so this was this hypothesis that I as a
person can jump I can be related to any
other person in this world like my
friendship by relationships by it by any
by any connection and I can reach anyone
in this world in less than six on
average in less than six jumps which
means that I can go from miracle to
Barack Obama in six jumps from me to
Donald Trump in six months six jumps so
like everyone is very connected this was
their hypothesis which is sometimes also
known as a small world hypothesis but
you know we live in a small world
so that's six degrees of separation and
people who have heard about el dos or
bacon number anyone can someone tell me
that your number is a one exactly so
like if you so Paul Erdos was a
researcher who used to travel around the
world and you know just pub like you
know collaborate with people and publish
papers and if you publish a paper with
Paul Erdos you get the number one if you
publish the paper with someone who has
published a paper with products you get
the number two and so on like Paul Erdos
is not there anymore so like getting the
number two is very prized like you know
it's it's a stupid thing but it
surprised a lot of people try to do that
and similarly there is a Kevin Bacon
number two which means that if you have
if you have worked in a film in which
Kevin Bacon was involved then you get
the number one if you are if you have
worked in a film with someone who was
involved with Kevin Bacon in their first
in their film and you get the number two
and so on and then there is a Kevin
Bacon number then there's a aldose bacon
number which is the sum of both and
apparently someone has number four so
that's pretty nice I guess
so in this in this exercise we try to
find the two to five zero four number of
the network and hence use shortest path
basically you try to find
the shortest path from every node 2 2 to
5 0 4 and stored that distance and then
we plot out a nice graph out of it
did anyone end up with this looking
graph I'm going to use the word plot no
because graph is confusing now this is a
graph network is a graph did any one end
up with this plot and what can we infer
from this plot look at the peak where is
it peeking thanks so did we just prove
six degrees of separation
no we didn't I'm not claiming anything
but you know there seems to be some
truth about this thing about this
hypothesis so if you want to do a more
thorough like proof of this for this
data set you should calculate the
distance between every two node in this
network and find the distribution of
that and to do that you basically
calculate the average shortest path
length in this in this network and you
will find that at six point zero four
that kind of peeks around at six so
maybe that's maybe that's something I'm
not claiming that proves anything but
maybe that's something so so actually
Facebook tried doing this like when they
had like one around one point four
billion people so they tried to find the
average shortest path length of their
network of the friendship Network you
know is connected to B B's friends with
CCS with D looked like this how can I go
to any other person on this on the
Facebook of friendship Network and like
in how many number of jumps and you
could see your number like you know your
degrees of separation but they removed
it now I don't know why but they removed
it and like I think for me it was like
three point one seven which means that
an average of three point one seven
jumps
I can reach anyone on Facebook and I
think that's pretty nice and I think I
think that's the biggest experiment that
you can do what with you know six
degrees of separation but again it it
has a lot of bias because the people who
are on Facebook participant or not on
Facebook
at different sets so you can't really
claim anything about this and I think
Jacobo had of two point eight so maybe
he knows about more people on Facebook
maybe not but he has access to the
database so he knows about everything so
okay so let's talk about Game of Thrones
now how many of you like Game of Thrones
okay how many of you don't like Game of
Thrones what no one that's surprising
how many of you don't care about Game of
Thrones even I don't care I just saw
Game of Thrones because because I have
to I can I have to create this tutorial
so it was for work so I didn't enjoy
Game of Thrones so so people who have
who like Game of Thrones have you seen
this has anyone seen this picture before
so like people who know Game of Thrones
will will see that this picture kind of
makes sense so basically this is the
larger the font the more important you
are
we don't know like how they define a
Protestant important like how important
you are right now but the larger the
fault more important you are and
according to the color you have your own
little communities or families as you
may say so this picture kind of makes
sense if you if you are familiar with
Game of Thrones so our aim in our aim in
the next thirty minutes is to understand
this picture in a better way so this was
done by this is done as an undergraduate
thesis project at Macalester College and
so basically they scraped the books and
you know created a network out of it and
the methodology for that was
if you have two characters in a 15 word
distance then you create an edge between
them I know this is not the best way of
doing it but this is one way of doing it
or one way of creating a network and and
the good thing about this is that
suppose you have things like the King
take that the Queen take that we don't
know which came or which Queen we are
talking about right so it had a lot of
manual work too so it's a pretty nice
Network in that and it's a pretty nice
data set in that way and they have a
blog too if you want to follow they keep
on doing new stuff network of Thrones
talk about pest calm so let's try to do
this let's load in the data set and if
you look at the data set it's so you
have a source you have a target you have
a type you have weight and book so type
is undirected that means the so in
networks there are two that fundamental
to write to that or networks its
undirected and directed in that an
undirected networks you have no
direction to the edges which is like
Facebook if I am friends with a that
person a is friends back with me if you
if that person it blocks me then we are
no more friends but in in Twitter for
example if I follow a person X that does
not necessarily mean X follows me back
so that's directed Network so that's the
difference here and in this data set all
all edges are undirected so that column
doesn't make any sense and even source
and target doesn't make any sense
because you have source and target only
when you have Direction involved that
you know you go from source to target so
so let's just treat them as two
different characters and the edge and
there's an edge between them and weight
and weight means the number of
interactions there are in that book and
how you define interaction is the number
of times you had character in the 15
word distance so for example
Aegon and Eddard Stark had four
interactions in book one according to
this data set so let's create graphs out
of it net force out of it and for
example if you look at a edge in this
network it's like Jaime Lannister and
Loras Tyrell had three like at three
interactions in book one this is like
the description of the data set so we
have five different we have five
different graphs for five different
books because there are like five books
right now you'll have a sex book
hopefully so now it now it's time for
the most important question of our life
know who is the most important character
why I why should they know I'm going to
try hard not to give any spoilers
because if you are still behind or
something but I'll try hard no
guarantees so let's try to find the most
important node in this network there's a
Jon Snow it's a Tyrion sec Tyrion
Lannister it's it's Daenerys we don't
know let's see what Matt still tells us
those maths is objective so that's good
so let's start with degree centrality
the one we did like we saw for authors
to find like who has the most like you
know who has the most interactions with
the most number of people which like
which character is connected to the most
number of characters and according to
the according to that Eddard Stark is
the most important character in book 1
and Jon Snow is the most important
character in book 5 and this kind of
makes sense if you if you know of
Thrones and like and you can see that
Eddard Stark is nowhere to be seen in
top 10 of book 5 something happened I
don't know what
something happened so again this is a
real world Network remember it's a real
world Network and we see a similar
exponential decay here so maybe that
model wasn't that off even with all its
criticism it's not that off we see a
exponential decay and this is a fancy
way of plotting the same thing it's a
log log plot of it if you are in
academia you will understand why I did
that because you know we like to things
we like to keep things fancy so time for
an exercise again let's create a new
measure which is called weighted degree
in which instead of just counting the
number of nodes we count the basically
sum of the weights of the adjacent nodes
Addyson edges roads let's do that and
let's let's see if that makes any
difference in our ranking of most
important characters
any questions any comments feel free to
ask
don't let any one end up with this
looking plot
Oh No so again dancers here are my
answers they're not the best answers
necessarily so that's one of the
shortcomings of Network X they do it
because the way they're the data
structure works is like it's you have to
you have to go inside the big story of
dixville layers to get stuff out and
that's why like apparently we may sprint
I don't know if they're a sprint say but
we may work on a new back-end for
Network X night by later maybe so if you
if you look at this plot again we find
kind of exponential decay and yeah maybe
maybe so did this maybe this works and
if we look at the new ranking according
to a new measure weight degree we see
that a dart stock is still the most
important one but it bumps up Jon Snow
from fifth position to the third
position in book one so maybe this is a
good centrality measure so let's do
let's do a new thing new centrality
measure which is called betweenness
centrality and check if that makes any
difference so so this is this is
something called a barbell graph as you
can see it's like a purple that's why
it's called a barber graph no surprises
there and if I ask you which is the most
important node in this network what
would you say
yeah I mean if you if you look at degree
if you look at this number of neighbors
then it's these two right but if you
look at if you if you try to find a node
which is somehow integral to the
structure of the network it's this node
right here even though it has only two
neighbors it's kind of important to the
overall structure because if you remove
this node if you do something to this
node you are breaking apart the network
sometimes it's a good thing but
sometimes it's a bad thing and maybe if
you don't want to do that so that's why
there is no right measure of centrality
there's no like look this is this is the
correct way of know with finding
importance of a node you need to you
need to first you need to find you know
why you want to do that and then you use
your different measures so in between
this entirety we basically find the node
the basic intuition behind that is we
find the node which is very important
for the connectedness of the network if
I remove this node I somehow increase
the average shortest paths of the
network so that's the intuition behind
that and and the math says it's it's
pretty simple maths that you calculate
the shortest path between every pair of
node and then you try to find the node
which has the most number of these paths
going through and in this case we this
this the middle or will will be that
node because every shortest path from
this this group of nodes to this group
of nodes have to pass through this so
this is the most important node
according to betweenness centrality so
let's see if if we use between a
centrality for Game of Thrones does that
make a difference so we see that again
I got stuck is the most important person
so maybe a dart stock is important and
if we so so you can do a weighted was a
weighted version of this an unweighted
version
and my weight I mean the number of
interactions that we had and we have
encoded that information to into the
network so let's use that so if I do a
weighted one I get Robert Baratheon has
the most important node but like it's
speck it's a it's a jump between one and
two so it's not that there's nothing
super surprising here so let's move to
another centrality module which is
called page strength anyone of anyone
who has heard of PageRank before so this
is so this was the billion this was a
twenty five billion dollar algorithm
which is page rank which is behind the
first version of Google so it's it's
named after Larry Page that's my page
rank and web page so you know page page
see that that's why Google worked and so
the basic intuition behind that is you
start the basic algorithm is that
suppose I am a random walk of my random
walk I mean like suppose this is the
this is a network and I put you randomly
on a node and I tell you you have a that
you know you have to jump around the
network and so basically the end result
is the node where you end up the most
number of times is an important note in
this network this is the basic intuition
behind this and we're going to see this
in a bit more detail later because this
makes a lot of sense for directed
networks it makes sense for undirected
to but for directed you have clear
examples so let's calculate PageRank
weighted and unweighted and we have a
dot stock for both of them so we have
like four to five different techniques
which have radically different ways of
calculating importance all of us tell
that a dart stock is important so yes I
think we can successfully conclude that
according to mathematics and in in the
in the first book of Game of Thrones
that stock is important so let's see if
there's a correlation between these
techniques this is interesting because
like the way these are calculated are
very different is there a correlation
between them it's exercise but let's we
we could run short of time so you know
let's not do that
we'll just see what's happening here so
if you try to find the correlation
between them you see there's a very high
correlation between weighted degree and
PageRank and which is kind of surprising
because these are very different
measures and the way they're calculated
are very different so that's interesting
but again like we're not we cannot claim
anything from this from these numbers so
keep that in mind so let's see how
characters evolved over the over the
over the books like you know from book 1
book 2 book 3 that things happen
storylines change can we find how how
fickle is life or your importance over
this over this over over this in this
fantasy world so let's do this for a
dart Terry and and John snow and we see
that there's a dad was the most
important person then a slight drop of
the ultimate demise into nothingness and
then we have like you know there's a
research from book 4 to book 5 for for
Jon Snow so like these things would
makes like these these things wouldn't
make sense if you like if you watch
corresponds and I'm sorry if you don't
for schema so don't remember these
things and or if you're behind and you
don't know what's going to happen
so obviously let's create a set of
characters this is just a very bad
looking code for for finding the top
five top five from a union of top Union
of talk from every book and that and
let's see the evolution of you know
how the importance wavers around so the
upon test you can zoom into this so we
see that at the end this is this is four
degree centrality and we see that this
is a dart stock and in the first book we
have John Snow and ten arrows Daenerys
and yeah this this makes sense if you
want this make sense that you know these
are these are the people who are
supposed to be the most important one at
least from subjective viewing of this
show and Matt's also point such towards
that so maybe what whatever we did in
the last 40 minutes wasn't a waste of
time maybe this is important so now
let's look for a different measure does
that tell us a different story and it's
loading and and it does tell us a
different story so this person right
here is not John Snow is not dinner as
it's Stannis Baratheon and that's kind
of feared Stannis Baratheon is he's not
a useless character character but he is
definitely not the most important
character if you ask someone what is
Game of Thrones
but according to betweenness centrality
is the most important character in book
4 and in book 5 why is that I don't know
I honestly don't know but we can infer
things because we know what betweenness
centrality is and we know he's the most
important character of wanting to
betweenness centrality so let's see
what's up with them
so this is my hypothesis so this is
what's happening so if you remember
something happened at the wall and so in
my hypothesis this is Stannis Baratheon
and he is the glue between two different
families or like I say communities in
the network and if you remove Stannis
Baratheon it will break apart the
network or it will it will reduce the
connectivity of the network so that's
why Stannis Baratheon is important so
so this is the surprising part of the
game of Thrones network analysis and
yeah and you see like no don't snow is
the degree centrality person who's the
most important one in book five and
Stannis Baratheon is the most important
or little betweenness centrality which
is a surprising result so now let's talk
about a new thing in networks which is
called which is a very hotly debated
research topic that's community
detection
it's hardly debated because no one knows
the definition of it like there is no
clear definition of what is a community
in a network so people just come up with
their own stuff and like they write a
paper so we're going to use something
called the one community detection
algorithm and let's not explain the
maths it's basically it tries to find
ten subclusters in the network we will
see what we will we look at what I mean
by that so suppose yes
so this is a community in a bigger game
of Thrones Network this is a sub
community of that yeah and we see that
connections here in this community are
very like tense like you know everyone
like it seems like everyone is connected
to each other and this is the same with
the like all other communities in the
network too like these are sub
communities yeah so I miss this one so
basically this is our fancy drawing plot
in which different colors represent
different communities and this is what
was the original picture but like python
is not that code for drawing stuff so
there are better tools out there that
that picture was from Caffey if you are
interested in like you know drawing
prettier networks then you should use
that and this is the community community
structure of our of our data set and if
we go back to this yep so if you see
that in sub communities you have more
denser connections so let's let's
actually check that if I find the
density of book 1 its 0.39 and if i try
to find the density of a subgraph which
is a community that's 0.229 that's like
it's 6 7x so like density is something
that could be used as a metric for
finding communities if you find clusters
which have a lot of n links and the
definition of density is pretty simple
it's like number of edges divided by
total number of edges possible like NC 2
that's like n into n minus 1 that's the
definition of density and yeah so it's
like a 5.83 jump so that's one way of
defining again this is not the only way
of defining or community this is one way
of defining a community another way is
like suppose I again it's it's something
like a random walking if I suppose I
drop you at one place do you end up in
similar nodes all the time if you
that happens tenure community if I drop
you at another place and then you keep
on circling around in some nodes a lot
of times and that is a community so
there are different ideas how to
calculate communities this is a famous
one because it's very fast again this is
the this algorithm is a heuristic it's
not a guaranteed optimal solution and
because if you define communities define
the community detection thing in this in
this way it's an np-hard problem so you
can't really solve that
it's a optimization problem then so if
we try to find the most important node
in every community we find that you know
these are the most important like
surprisingly there are Sansa Stark and
Catelyn Stark are in different
communities in book one I don't know why
but surprised I think they are we
already talked about talked about power
loss in the network so let's not do that
so let's open the second notebook now
leave which is about us airports so is
there a aviation geek in the in the in
our audience today ok so I'm the only
one so so this is a data set from the
transportations there's statistics FAA
and in this data set you have all the
domestic flights from 1990 to 2015 like
the key word is domestic from like a
domestic airport and us to another
domestic I put in the US and so let's
try to like we're gonna do a similar
thing let's try to find which are the
most important airports any guesses
before we start Chicago and any other
guesses JFK any other guesses LAX any
other guesses sure obviously are you
from Charlotte
so we have we have very different but
surprise surprise all of you are drunk
so so this is the data set you have like
an origin destination and like the
airline name and number of passengers
that traveled that that travel that
route and this is from nine that this is
this is a 1991 so you'll see a lot of
now-defunct headlines so and in this
case we will create a multi digraph so
in networks you have a graph you have a
digraph it is a directed graph and then
you have multi graph and multi diagraph
it is a multi directed graph which means
that first of all you're allowed to have
directions like this is a directed graph
because suppose you okay like it should
show this network be a directed graph or
an undirected graph because I already
told that it supposed to be a directed
graph and like like in in it's in an
ideal case it should be a direct it's
like it should be able we should be able
to model this as a and I think graph
because if there's a flight from A to B
they should be effect from V to a but we
seal that it's not the case it like
there are some routes in this dataset in
which you go to point B and there is no
way back like you can just go anywhere
from that Airport I don't know how that
happens yeah so in multi directed graph
we have multiple edges between nodes and
in our case nodes our airports and every
edge is here like like for 1990 I have
an edge for 90 91 we have an edge from a
nearly to gamma H and so on so let's see
Cleveland to Chicago I really need to
change this text it's because this is
JFK to SFO so let's look clear under
Chicago instead if we do Cleveland to
Chicago so we see that in year 2014
three hundred thousand people flew plane
went to Chicago on these airlines yeah
this nice now let's see the evolution
like you know how things changed and you
know passenger traffic
this is from JFK to SFO and you see that
this like like this is a general trend
in the whole data set you will see
seasonality and dip at 2001 after 9/11
which was I think actually which was
exaggerated by the tech bubble and
that's why you see a bigger dip and then
you see a dip here during the recession
but you don't see a very big dip here
but in some roots if you go looking
you'll find the guide F during the
recession so this is a passenger graph
for for JFK so far in 2014 I think yeah
so time for an exercise so the excel is
to find the most like the most number of
passengers that flew in 1990 do you have
to find the busiest flights the the
busiest flight paths in 1990 and 2015
and we have time so we can do the
exercises
[Applause]
and there are two ways of doing this one
is to create a network like use the
network and try to find by ight rating
through all the nodes that will take a
lot of time because then it will its
Python it's slow and the faster way is
just using some fancy pandas and like if
you are comfortable with pandas you'll
end up with something like this and if
we see that in the year 1990 it's al
it's from Los Angeles to Honolulu is the
busiest route and 2015 its annex to SFO
so yeah so let's see how it changed over
the years so this is what happened to
Hawaii like like I tried doing this with
different date puts in Hawaii I thought
maybe you know there's this new Airport
which has more traffic so people are
flying to that Airport but apparently
that's not the case the traffic to to
Hawaiian airports has been in a downward
trend apparently Hawaii is not cool
anymore and people want to go there so I
don't know what - what - how to fix that
but this is what this is this is the
passenger traffic from LAX to Hawaii
from 1990 or 2015 this is for LAX to SFO
thinkyeah SFO and you see like no the
the usual deep here and surprisingly nor
the back or not even a depth after the
recession so maybe people from my legs -
as a foot in Turley or rich they didn't
care about that so so let's create a
2015 passenger graph and where 2015 I
mean like that's extract net for for
2015 it was we're gonna play around with
that
this is the lat/long of
all the airports and will not do this
exercise if we plot the if we plot the
the airports
you'll see something like this and you
see there are a lot of airports in
Alaska and keep that in mind because
that will be important later on there
are a lot of airports in Alaska and you
will see these airports and these both
are considered domestic because I think
they are like if there's US military
bases then the flights between them or I
think considered domestic that's why you
have them this is the same thing just
plotted in a different way so what about
the degree distribution remember this is
a real world Network and here we go an
exponential decay again so maybe just
maybe those people weren't that crazy
yes it does follow exponential decay for
real world networks and and we'll plot a
log-log plot just to make things fancy
and like you know in a perfect it's not
just to make things fancy but in a
perfect exponential degree you will see
a straight line but you will see but
this is this is not exactly following a
power law you will see you will see this
straight trend rather than a straight
line so going back to PageRank so this
is a very famous pictorial
representation of PageRank this is what
you will get if you go to Wikipedia so
so in this how this were and these are
this is a directory network and this is
the percentage sign is the importance of
the load in the network which means that
like like the surprising thing is if you
look at note C there is only one
incoming connection and if we go back to
degree centrality which realized just on
number of current connections
that doesn't make sense she shouldn't be
that important it has only one
connection like only one one website
points towards point C do not see why is
that about it the reason for that is
because it is pointed towards by B which
is in itself important and a lot of not
so important websites point towards P
which inflates B and and traverses
through B to see the importance so this
is the idea behind page rank
Oh a pretty picture pictorial idea man
his rank and then we're going to use
that in US airports and try to find the
most important airport using maybe
patient just to get a better example in
this we create a directed network in
which every node is pointing towards
node 2 if we try to find the page rank
no surprises we find 2 as the most
important node because everyone is
pointing towards 0.2 so they are like
pumping up the importance of node 2 so
any guesses what would happen by adding
on H between 5 and 6 this is 5 and this
is 6 we idle it's like this will this
change the importance of 2 or somehow
change our results significantly any
ideas
like what
should be the most important node now is
it still too was it made if I use it
maybe six or maybe one yeah it should
still do and we will just see that six
is a big pumped up because you have one
more connection pointed towards six but
it's it's still two but what if we add
an edge from two to eight there's a new
edge which points from two to eight
which is the which should be the most
important node now
but I heard it too and I ate and it just
happened that eight is the most
important node but it's not a like you
can do you mind just look at the picture
actually you know answer the question I
know which is the most important node
but we know that too and it both are
important and you see and you see that
in the desert it's like no point three
to four and point three to nine so it
doesn't really make a difference but
because eight is pointed towards pie
eight eight is empower it is important
so let's move back to airports and use
our newly gained twenty five billion
dollar algorithm knowledge and we find a
and C HP n as the most important inputs
anyone who knows a and see what what's a
NC and courage is that is that
surprising for you yeah and it's written
for a lot of people I mean for obvious
reasons so and even HP and is a I don't
know money but even HP resume put in in
Alaska and according to according to our
analysis our mathematical analysis of as
our sound mathematical analysis its
Anchorage so what happened sorry
yeah I mean like this is the like this
is my like this is what I tell myself
what happens is that what happened is
that because there are a lot of flights
from a lot of important it puts in the
mainland us to Anchorage it pumps up the
waters of Anchorage and because
Anchorage will seem between us ontology
to in between us interrogate again
Anchorage and because I am courageous
connected to a lot of local air puts in
in Alaska which don't have direct flight
from all the major a puts in in mainland
us that bumps up the betweenness
centrality score of Anchorage because
it's connecting a lot of local airports
to mainland us and if you remove if you
shut down at Airport
you are breaking apart the network
you're decreasing the connectivity of
the of this USA Pro Network but when you
calculate degree centrality you get the
usual people that you know you expect
you have Atlanta you have Chicago you
have 10 world we have LAX too and
there's a nice blog post about this if
you want to read more about this because
there are people who argue about the
reasons of you know why this is
happening so this is a nice blog post if
you want to read and has a nice comments
that comment section to which has more
debate about this the link is in the
jupiter notebook and so if we look at
the weighted version okay again like
disclaimer right now we just saw the
structure of the network which means
that if there is a edge between New York
to San Francisco it doesn't matter if
there are millions of people flying it
doesn't matter if there are thousand of
flights I treat that I treat that as one
if there's an edge if there's a flight
from New York to LA again I treat that
as one these are same edges there's no
there's no more information between
these edges but as soon as I do waited
when I had information about number of
passengers that are flowing through this
network I get kind of different results
I get
Seattle as the most important you
port for betweenness centrality it's
happening it will comes here to
hopefully so Seattle is the most
important for betweenness centrality and
for PageRank you have I think Chicago
let's wait yeah so we have Seattle as
the most important maple now but like
Nancy is still at number two but at
least by adding more information to the
network by like know the number of
passengers that are flowing around we
kind of caught a more CN result I'd you
know when you penny says Seattle is is
an important type of people say fine
okay maybe but when you say I'm gonna
like I'm Curtis is a is the more
surprising one and in page that we have
like when we do the weighted one with
the number of passengers flowing we have
a better list now we have Atlanta
Chicago we have Seattle and we have
Anchorage which is pumped down to fourth
position now so but we can see that like
doesn't matter how you try to model and
quit is still up there some somewhere so
I've got is is important maybe not the
most important but ankle is is an
important airport let's just keep the
that's the takeaway from this debacle
so another like suppose we live in a
nice socialist society where where the
government cares about its citizen and
like people are like you know that
they're doing things you know just to
make everyone's life easier so and in
that case and you are head of the
Aviation Department in that case you
would like to decrease the average
shortest path of this network and what
do we mean by average shortest path I
like the number of flights I should take
from four to reach from point A to point
B should be less than maybe like tool I
shouldn't be able to I don't have like
three or four layer of three or four
layers if I want to
one place in us to the another place in
the u.s. that that's what I mean by like
no in decreasing the average shortest
path length let's try to calculate that
and we get an error so we get this error
called graph is not weakly connected
okay let's just focus on connected not
weakly graph is not connected that seems
dumb because that that means that there
are eight put some Jewess which you
cannot reach for example from any like
like I'm not seeing a direct flight like
that there's no way of reaching that
Airport doesn't matter how many jumps
you make and that seems weird and dumb
so how let's let's let's have a look at
that
when we calculate the weakly connected
components we see that this is one
component which has all the airports and
if we go down keep on going down there
are these three airports so there is
this one component for SP BN SSB and
then there is one component aik so that
a put is in itself there's a flight from
aik to EA k so does anyone know these
airports so apparently there's this
seaplane company it's so it's a it's a
seaplane Airport so there's the seaplane
company which flies from SP v to SP v
SSB so I mean that's okay they it's a
seaplane company which is you know just
keep on flying between these two
airports but make a still a mystery to
me if anyone finds out what's wrong with
the egg is tell me so so this is the
data set there is a flight from aik to
aik there are zero passengers I don't
know how many went down but nobody went
came down but there are zero passengers
and again these are not charter services
these are scheduled flights so you can't
like this is not a fun ride over let's
just go for a spin it's not like no like
someone flew from LAX and I guy I will
come back to either X these are
scheduled flights so this is a normally
in the data database maybe so let's just
remove them because we don't care about
them so now we have a weakly connected
Graff but what is but we don't have a
strongly connected graph and what does
that mean let's have a look at that so
suppose this is our director Network
like like strongly and weekly only makes
sense in directed graphs they have no
use in undirected graphs so this is a
directed graph and if I if I throw
myself on any node I can go to any other
node in this network right doesn't
matter if I throw myself here I can
still reach this node by going through
this code so you can traverse the whole
network if you are anywhere so that's
what a strongly connected graph is I can
reach every other node in a in a
directed graph doesn't matter where I
start from but suppose I have this edge
if I throw you down here there is no
coming back
whoopsy so this is this is not a
strongly connected graph so that's and
so you do so you do realize what happens
now this air put network is not strongly
connected even after removing those
anomalies so apparently there are
airports like this to which you can fly
to but you cannot come back I mean like
these are scheduled like these are these
are mostly like press free services in
which they have like this is my initial
investigation was that these are field
services which which would fly to these
places but they I think they don't have
a scheduled you know going back like
planes don't stay that they fly to
someplace else but these and those are
not scheduled flights that's why they
are not in the database so let's change
the strongly connected thing so these
are like these this is a long list of
airports which are like nowhere you can
go to but or you can go from but you
cannot go back so let's just remove them
for example like so this is like there's
a FedEx flight flight or mode Ont 2tsp
so you can go to TSP but you cannot come
back let's create a strong version of
this graph which is like a strongly
connected version then we find that the
average shortest path length in this
network that we created seen and network
we created is I think three point zero
five four yeah three three point one
seven and that means that there are like
like on average if I go I want to go
from LAX to any other small airport
maybe this is the average number of
flights like I have to I have to lay
overs because there are three flights so
I have to lay overs and that's what I
mean two levels are okay because us is a
big country but so if you solve this
game I think you should probably give
you a solution to like airlines and
other people but so the game is you can
add 500 new flights to this network but
you have to decrease that average
shortest path length and so like I like
my my my approach is a pretty naive
approach so basically what I do is I
find as I find daily centrality of the
network and then I sort it by like of
decreasing degree centrality and I try
to connect airports with the highest
degree centrality which are not
connected yet and I just go and I had
500 new connections and when I do that I
get a decrease in my think
like I'd rather decrease it degrees to
3.08 this is not that good of a decrease
because I added like 500 new flights and
assuming there is I don't care about
financial viability I just want to do it
for the common good
I want to decrease this decrease this
number and yeah this is a game if if we
have feel feel feel feel free to do the
success is if you want to and feel free
to share ideas too you don't have to
actually code it can anyone think of a
better way of adding new flights to
decrease the shortest path length yes
that's someone did suggest a very
similar idea last time I gave this
tutorial and all right actually worked
because when they did that is the number
4 - I think 2.94 so that's a that's a
good way of connecting new airports but
again that's probably because it's not
financially viable but assuming we live
in an ideal world
any more ideas of helping the world
become a better place
oh wait this is LA there's no decimal
anyone should be move forehead maybe if
you calculate your centrality every time
you add an edge from the most central so
each new time finding the central things
you just throw that connection yeah
that would totally work so like he says
he said I said that every time I add an
image I recalculate my centrality so
that you know I have a better picture
rather than you know using the one that
I already had that should probably be
better than this so let's just let's go
ahead and so let's try to focus on one
airline United because I have a very
complicated love/hate relationship with
them and so let's play play around with
the network so okay so let's extract
United graph which is basically a flight
for United and let's see what happens
with that
so in this graph it's four so we have
2015 flight flights of United and the
length of this network is by length I
mean the number of nodes which is 134
so in this data set we have 134 nodes
airports which have United flights and
there are 1,100 flights between them
again this is the number of routes this
is not the number of flights so that's a
difference here so it's for example like
there are I think there are 25 flights
between New York and Chicago just by
United but that's counted as one in this
one so keep that in mind so when we
calculate PageRank for this network we
find it's it's Chicago it's Denmark it's
LA SFO it Dow Washington and new vaca
klonda's and when you open the Wikipedia
page of United you will find these are
the hubs and the so-called hubs of
united so so this data set and this
analysis this kind of it works it was
you because these are the actual hubs of
united so so we know that PageRank works
to give us what's important for United
and degree centrality also gives out us
goes out like similar airports so
exercise we are new of no we are not in
New York but I gave this tutorial like
two days back at PI data New York so I
didn't change that sorry about that so
let's try to find like how things
changed for United from the three
airports of New York that's JFK Newark
and LaGuardia so if you look at the if
you look at this the number of
passengers that are flowing out of this
Airport you see a very subtle spike from
this to this in 2011 or 12 I guess
that's because continental and United
modes and continental and Newark was the
hub for continental so you
see the sudden spike and and you have
different you don't have this spike in
JFK because like they like it wasn't
really a hop for any of them so it just
they just have their similar traffic and
you this and and you have a spike in
LaGuardia because I think you right it
had a hub there so I'm continental
flight stowing that count so yep that's
it we go back and add Continental to
your United States since yeah good if
you have we probably should like we
should either flights from corn but or
maybe we should we shouldn't no we have
to do one thing we have maybe we should
add flights from Continental 3 2012
before the merger because before that
they're different so any more questions
comments that's it thank you
[Applause]